so at this point i'm kind of i've hit a
brick wall um maybe i've made a chip in
it maybe not um i need to think about
the broader context of the question
because remember this is not just a
standalone question this is part three
of three so could one part one or part
two help us and the answer is go back
and have a look at part two
write down the contrapositive of the
proposition p
g that's sticking out like a sore thumb
isn't it right um why would they ask us
to tell us what a contrapositive is and
then then it just sort of disappears off
into the night right now part three i'll
admit and this is why i think a lot of
the state missed this when they did this
last year part three doesn't give you a
big like slap in the face clue it
doesn't say
hence or otherwise prove blah blah blah
blah but the the mere presence of part
two which doesn't seem to flow off of
part one in any obvious way and you know
like they don't make it really really
clear in an explicit form how you're
gonna use in part three but its mere
presence should clue you into the fact
that it might be useful and the problem
that i've emerged
into here is that going from a k q plus
1 expression
it's pretty hard to get to a k plus 1
expression but the reverse
is not true and that's what the
contrapositive does right it reverses
the flow of logic from a implies b we
get not b implies not
a
so what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to take this this is the converse
right
and i'm going to write the
contrapositive
of the converse let me say that and i'm
going to write it in really obvious
colors right the contrapositive
of the converse
of p
that's what i'm after here right because
um if i can get that right it'll get the
the k plus one term is the one we can
sort of manipulate right i will have to
do something with it because not
divisible by three so it's a little bit
tricky but i'll deal with that in a
second and it will help me use the clue
that part two is nudging us toward okay
so what am i required to prove
i don't need these brackets here right
i'm required to prove i'm gonna go
not uh here we go
not
a implies not b because this is the
converse and i want the contrapositive
of this not the contrapositive of p
the contrapositive of p is converse okay
so i'm gonna go not a implies not b so
it's going to look like this
if k plus 1
is not divisible by 3
there's not a
then
here comes not b
k cubed plus one
is not divisible by three
and whenever i negate something i like
to make it very obvious which is why you
can see me using all caps for the word
not okay
this is what i want to try and prove so
then the question that naturally springs
from this is well i have to write some
kind of statement right if i go back to
part one i could easily write a
statement that goes with a i'm trying to
write a statement that goes with not a
what does it look like what can i say
about k plus 1 if it is
not divisible by 3 well i guess i could
say let's just grab this right i could
say well the negation of that
could look like this right k plus 1 is
not equal to 3
m the problem with me is this uh
this in equation this thing that is not
true it's kind of hard to work with
right because i need to prove i need i
want to work from things that are true
this is not a proof by contradiction
right i want to work from things that
are true and then see how the logical
implications flow from those right so
rather than say something is not true
if k plus 1 isn't divisible by 3
it can't be written in the form 3n but i
can write it in some other forms right
here are my multiples of 3 in here if i
just fill this in and have a look at the
rest of the numbers right if i have 2
and then 4 and 5 and then 7 and 8 i
can't write any of these numbers in the
form 3n but i can write them in other
forms right say for example um four and
seven they're both bigger than a
multiple of three right so they're of
the form three n
plus one
three n plus one it's just a different n
in each case and in much the same way if
you have a look at my other
not divisible by 3s they're all one less
than a multiple of 3. so 2 is a 3n minus
1 type number 5 is also a 3n minus 1
type number and so is eight
so i could write it like that or i could
say it's like three n plus two
three n plus two these are all different
ways to write all of the same kinds of
not divisible by three numbers okay and
every number that's not divisible by
three will fall into one of these two
categories so that's what i'm going to
use this is sort of like a proof by
exhaustion a proof by looking at
separate cases so let's break it apart
like so i'm going to call this case 1
and case 2.
if k plus 1 is not divisible by 3 then i
can say either k plus 1 will look like
this
3n plus 1
or k plus one will look like this i'll
go with the positive one because
negatives hurt my brain okay three n
plus two and in each of these cases k
and n are going to be
integers yeah so what i want to prove
that's a terrible curly brace let's fix
that there we go what i want to show
is that the k2 plus one that goes with
each of these cases is not divisible by
three so we were trying to get to three
times some stuff here i want to get to
three times some stuff plus a one or
plus a two because if i plus three then
i'm back to being divisible by three
again okay
so i if you've been following so far
you've actually got the hardest part of
the logic down but let's actually tie
this up in a neat bow right let's do
case one first i'm going to subtract 1
from both sides like so and then i'm
going to cube because that will get me
to the k q plus 1 that i'm after so
whoopsie daisy this should be a 27 n
cubed i'm now going to add 1
to both sides that gives me this
and hopefully you can see here like this
is the kq plus one that i want to show
isn't divisible by three and this right
hand side
sure enough is not divisible by three i
can prove it here's the part that is
divisible by three
that three lots of a thing and then you
just got this pesky plus one hanging out
the end here right so that can't
possibly be divisible by three
so that's it for case one let's have a
look at case two
i'm going to pull the same trick i'm
going to subtract 1 from both sides that
gives me this
i'm still going to cube because i still
need a k cubed plus 1 eventually but i
have to think a little more carefully
when i'm doing this
binomial expansion so it's going to be
and tell me if i'm getting this right i
think it should be 27
n cubed 27 n squared
this is going to be 9 m and then it's
just a 1 on the end
by the way if you're wondering where i
got these coefficients from it's that
there's going to be one lot of the 3n
term all cubed and then there's going to
be three lots of
this squared and one of these and then
three lots
of just one of these so i'm climbing
down my binomial um coefficients there
um but when you when you multiply this
by itself three times you get the 27
there um you get two lots of the or two
what's the word i'm looking for lots is
not right that's multiplication two
exponents of that and then you multiply
by this binomial coefficient and so on
you can do the expansion and prove to me
whether that's right or wrong
i need to add one to both sides like i
did before so there
comes that and then i'm going to be a
little cheap just because i'm watching
the clock that's going to be plus 2 and
just like before i can pull out a factor
of 3 from some of this line but not all
of it right i can say there's going to
be a 9n cubed a 9n squared and then a 3n
uh and those that's all an integer but
then you've got this pesky plus 2
hanging around so just like before this
is not divisible by 3.
okay so what i've proven is this
statement here right and this is the
contrapositive so i can say
since
the not a implies not b statement i just
proved that that's true
like so
since that's true i can say by the
contrapositive that the contrapositive
this is true right and that's b oopsie
daisy b
implies a in other words that's the
converse i was after um
b implies a by the contrapositive
so
uh by the way i should just add one more
little fun fact which is not necessary
but it's kind of cute this thing that we
just proved here
not a implies not b this has a name as
well it's not the converse
it's the inverse the contrapositive of
the converse not part of the course but
you can see how it's been used it just
didn't give you the word inverse then
you call it that but you still had to
use it and it's obviously in the course
because it got tested in last year's hsc